[Music]
here we go again sony have revealed the
free games for us ps plus subscribers
for the month of september 2021. like
always we can download the following
games from the first tuesday of the
month which is the seventh first up is
overcooked all you can eat this is a
social game about running a restaurant
against the clock sounds simple i know
but in no time at all you'll be burning
all the food starting fires in the
kitchen and someone always forgets to
wash up i can guarantee you need strong
relationships with the people you play
with because overcooked gets stressful
quickly all you can eat is essentially
the entire collection of overcooked
games one and two and every single piece
of dlc and additional content thrown in
there's even new stuff just for this
edition including kitchens chefs and
challenges there's over 200 levels to
churn through on your way to the
platinum trophy overcooked won't be a
game you play daily after the first week
but dusting it off every month or so to
change up your gaming schedule is worth
the download i highly recommend adding
this to your collection and to confirm
overcooked all you can eat support cross
play so if your friends own this on pc
xbox or switch there's no barriers to
playing together game number two is
predator hunting grounds i've been
expecting this on ps plus for a year now
and finally it's here hunting grounds is
an asymmetric multiplayer game which
means there are more players on one side
than the other this time one player
becomes the predator and hunts down a
team of four special op soldiers
controlled by other real-life players
the ops team can win either by taking
out the predator or collecting intel and
eliminating a third faction a rebel
militia in the jungle controlled by ai
if you've played dead by daylight or
friday the 13th you'll get the core idea
here playing as the predator is
ridiculous fun as we have all the
gadgets from the movies including iconic
death animations playing as the soldiers
is a little less fun especially if they
don't play the objective i played
predator hunting grounds on release and
i have to admit it did not run very well
at all on ps4 and most reviews came out
at around 6 out of 10 but i've been
assured much work has gone into predator
over the last 12 months and it's a
better experience in 2021 so will you be
trying it please sound off in the
comments below and finally hitman 2 an
assassination simulation with everyone's
favorite slap heads agent 47 i adore
this franchise but the thing most new
players don't expect is how slow and
methodical hitman games are this is far
from a typical action game 47 must first
watch his targets finding their routines
and chances to take them out finding
disguises and blending in is actually
more important than the silver ballers
he carries the mastery of hitman is
eliminating a target in a way which
looks like an accident poisoning their
food dislodging a railing pushing them
into an oncoming f1 car they're very
subtle you'll be playing the same
missions over and over again to find
every way to off that person that's the
replay value of this game is finding
multiple ways to take them out and may i
recommend an exploding golf ball or
covering a target in cement there is a
story line in hitman but it's paper thin
so jump in wreck a few criminal
masterminds by dropping a toilet on
their heads and get out unseen job done
hitman 2 reviews average at 8 out of 10
so you know this is actually the highest
rated ps plus game we've had for a while
now definitely worth your time so there
we have it those were the games that
will get you through the month of
september 2021 are you happy sad
delighted or mad please leave a comment
to help this video get to other people
i'm adam you're awesome see ya